there seems to be a total lack of
comprehension on this panel and indeed
amongst this audience which is a
remarkable audience even even by even by
the left-wing standards of the BBC I'm
in this lot pretty left hang on a
seven-day hang on a second and we'll
know now just say one thing
yeah this is an audience being carefully
chosen not a rated NBC not by the BBC by
an independent polling organization to
represent the balance between all
parties never agree very good I think
it's very interesting never a great idea
to attend oh yes I Julie my own my
husband the head of the real audience
are sitting at home actually the you
cannot elect that no hang on no let my
say no no that's fine
no everyone it remarkable we are talking
about a market folks I know none of you
have ever worked in business but we're
talking about a market and markets are
about demand and supply and I just
wonder I'm curious can I get any
recognition from any of you that the
demand side of this equation is that a
rapidly rising population due to
open-door immigration started by Ed
Miliband's Labour Party in the late
1990s has directly contributed towards
the housing crisis is there any flicker
of recognition from any of you please
sort one of you have a go please we have
a